hey guys it's Jonah here so I'm really
excited to be making this video sports
drinks if you're an active person you
either drink this on a regular basis or
you must have at least try two sports
drinks before so there will be a lot of
information in this video if you want to
learn more about food nutrition and have
a better understanding on fitness I
would encourage you to sign up to the
National Academy of Sports Medicine &
ASM online personal training cause they
are currently offering a 14-day free
trial and this can also be this step for
you to get into the fitness industry so
I am a certified women's fitness
specialist with the NASM and I would
encourage you to click on the link in my
description box and get more information
right let's get into it so sports drinks
do you really need to rehydrate with
sports drinks what is the purpose of
sports drinks and what are the
ingredients in them so before I get into
more details the first thing you have to
understand is what are electrolytes
electrolytes are like a good power line
of our body they conduct electrical
signals that maintain fluid levels in
the body and also muscle function so
when we talk about electrolytes we're
talking about sodium potassium calcium
and also be carbonates drinking water to
rehydrate is a must in any physical
activity our body loses water quicker
than it loses electrolytes so if it's a
less intense workout under one hour it
is not necessary to rehydrate with
sports drinks but it is a very intense
workout for a long duration of time then
your body will lose water and
electrolytes through sweating especially
sodium and potassium so the function of
sports drinks is to instantly hydrate
your body replace fluid and electrolytes
loss through sweat and also to provide
you with instant energy while despite
what manufacturers would want you to
believe making your own sports drinks
it's not rocket science
so let's break it down in a sports drink
there are essentially four main
ingredients water
sodium and potassium water a general
rule is that we lose about one liter for
every hour of intense exercise and we
need to replenish the water lost sugar
which is also your refined cups provide
instant fill and energy to the muscles
sodium or salt contains electrolytes and
minerals which helps speed up hydration
maintain fluid balance and also reduces
and drillin levels during exercise so
you want to go for only high-quality sea
salt to get all the mineral benefits and
potassium potassium is also a very
important electrolyte which helps
transport glucose to your muscle cells
and regulate your body's water balance
so the average adult loses about 100 to
200 milligrams of potassium per hour of
endurance activity so for every 1 to 2
hours of endurance activity you want to
consume about 200 to 300 milligrams of
potassium if your electrolyte supplies
stays low you will start to experience
headache fatigue dizziness irritable
muscle cramps and your muscles may even
continue to feel weak during your next
workout session so electrolytes are
important not just after workout but
also to help you to increase your
overall workout performance I know that
it is very easy to grab and overprice
sports drinks off the shelf but are they
really all that healthy for you most of
the time store-bought sports drinks tend
to contain more than what we really need
especially artificial sugar flavor and
also coloring just to make them look
more attractive to us natural is always
the better option plus it is so cheap
healthier and it is so easy to make so
I'm going to share with you 5 homemade
sports drinks which you can make in less
than 5 minutes and you can take it out
with you to the gym or outdoors each of
this recipe makes 2 cups of 500
milliliters enjoy
you
and finally I want to introduce to you
to the amazing coconut yup coconut water
is often referred to as the nature's
sports drinks so one cup of coconut
water has 600 milligrams of potassium
252 milligrams of sodium and 6.2 gram of
sugar this is the perfect drink to
rehydrate the body and to replenish lost
electrolytes and this is why most
athletes swear by this so growing up in
Malaysia which is a very hot and humid
country we do drink coconut water almost
on a daily basis especially if we have
been under the heat for a long time it
is so cheap and so refreshing it is only
about $1 for one young coconut which is
way cheaper than any sports drinks so
guys if you live in Asia
don't bother wasting your money on
sports drinks just get a young coconut
by the street and drink it it is so much
better and cheaper so I hope you enjoyed
this video I know that there are a lot
of information in this video but I hope
that you can take this information and
apply it into your fitness routine and
to help you increase your workout
performance if you find this video to be
helpful be sure to give it a thumbs up
like and do subscribe to my youtube
channel for more weekly videos and do
follow me on my social media pages as
well at Joanna so official and guys do
watch the recommended videos right at
the end of this all the best
you